this is uh reported by the blaze
ukrainian citizens have allegedly taken
to publicly shaming those who decide to
take advantage of the war-caused chaos
to do a bit of looting according to
ukraine's correspondent
one enterprising citizen who decided to
take advantage of an understaffed store
chose to buy something there without
money the looter was unlucky he was seen
by local residents they called the
police to the place uh the arriving
patrol found the marauder without pants
and taped to a pole
so
okay here's the guy that's the looter
i guess other citizens saw this guy
looting
and so they taped him to a pole
and they pulled his pants out and taped
them to a pole just kind of like public
shaming thing this is also sort of the
spider-man
strategy of uh you know you don't have
the you don't have the the webs the
indestructible webs but he kind of you
know
ties him to a pole let the police show
up so that's what the ukrainians did
here i think there are other do we have
other
photos as well
okay there's another guy taped to a poll
public shaming he's got a sign on i
assume that says looter or something
like that
um
and then here's these guys okay these
guys were stripped naked
and they had i assumed something like
looter written across their bodies
blindfolded
and paraded through the street
by concerned citizens
more people those people are tied to
polls with their pants down
so now for me look this is this is still
a little bit too lenient for me
um i would like it if i you know maybe
and i understand that the resources and
everything are not uh
maybe don't allow for this but in an
ideal world you would do this and then
you would also have a supply of like
tomatoes and rotten eggs which again you
know war-torn country they're not going
to have that but if we were to adopt
this here then you know you tied to a
pole put the sign on them looter and
then you have um
you know crates of rotten uh uh eggs and
tomatoes and things and people could
come by and just have fun throwing them
and you keep them you keep them attached
to that pole for you know a day two days
or so
i think that's a great strategy
um i really appreciate that
so well done ukraine
imagine if we were to
adopt something like that in san
francisco
maybe not san francisco now i think you
know the problem is in san francisco if
you make them march through the street
naked they might like it too much
so
some kind of public shaming mechanism is
the appropriate response
and a lot of times that could be even
better than
yeah if you can send him to prison
that's also good
but public shaming is um
is is a real tool that societies have in
their belt
that these days we don't use anymore
because we have this idea that you
should never shame anyone it's always
bad to make people feel ashamed
well no
actually the equation is pretty simple
you should not shame people for doing
things that are not shameful
okay and this is what we get wrong this
is what cancel culture gets wrong
much of the time is that people are
getting shamed for doing things
that aren't shameful or shame for doing
things that don't really matter you know
um
but if someone is doing something that
is shameful like looting is a shameful
activity
to do it while your country is under
siege
and people are dying and you're taking
advantage of that
that's shameful
in some ways it's even more shameful
because at least in that case you can
claim that you were desperate you had no
choice i don't buy it but you could
claim that
it's even more shameful to do it in our
country but we're not under any official
military siege
and you're taking advantage of the fact
that the police aren't enforcing the law
and you are victimizing
and exploiting your fellow community
members the people who run these shops
these are these aren't millionaires
living on uh
in mansions
50 miles away these are people in your
community that you're victimizing
and yes you should be shamed for that
it's a good tool that we should be using
more often if you enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up and share it
with all your friends